President Trump said it earlier this
evening the gradual reopening of America
is already underway joining me now to
talk about that and more one of the
newest members of the Trump
administration team White House press
secretary Kelly mcenany Kelly happy
birthday thanks for being here Kelly
you're welcome the president talked
about the gradual reopening and talked
about Texas and Vermont why those two
and what can we expect after that well
the president has set the parameters to
reopen the country it's important to
know this is in line with medical
experts I've been in the task force
meetings I saw them come up with these
guidelines he's eager to reopen the
country and as he has said for weeks I
can do two things at once I can keep the
health and well-being of American
citizens first and reopen the country
and unleash the hottest economy in
modern history which President Trump put
together and Texas is taking steps
Florida's taking steps and these states
are moving forward because it's the
right time to do so as as the governors
have decided okay and you know speaking
of the governor's Governor Cuomo was
saying you know we need we need money
from the federal government we need more
from the federal government I mean what
is the President or what is the federal
government going to do in terms of
individual states like New York well
first let's go to the Constitution and
the way that governing works and the
states are supposed to take the lead on
having ventilators and testing and
supplies but nevertheless despite the
fact that it's the responsibility of
states this president has stepped up
this president when New York was saying
we need 40,000 ventilators 37,000
ventilators President Trump sent tons
and tons of insulators and in fact so
many that New York is saying we actually
don't need these and they're sending
them to other states as Washington has
done as California has done
president Trump stepped up despite it
being the state's responsibility to
stockpile okay and you know the
president also stepped up in record time
and the Democrats and the progressives
and the mainstream media said it would
never happen and that is by bringing the
naval ships in and actually dredging its
way into the
beer in New York and yet those are empty
are some of these governor's like being
a little overdramatic in terms of what
they want from the federal government
yeah there's been a lot of requests and
this president has been very strategic
and seeing what the need is not the ask
but the need he's deployed resources
accordingly where we can now say that
not a single American has died for lack
of a ventilator that's because of
President Trump I mean this is the
greatest mobilization judge since World
War two the greatest mobilisation of
American society private-sector
ingenuity what this president has done
in testing is now the new thing the
media is talking about well guess what
this president has overseen the four
million tests being conducted more than
that two times more than any country on
the face of this earth it's
extraordinary okay good but let but let
me ask you this Kelley there's different
tests there there's a testing to
determine whether or not you have the
virus and then there's a test to
determine whether you have the antibody
which apparently is even more available
so which test should people be taking
yeah so the experts have distinguished
between these two and it's really
important the diagnostic test was the
first phase of the testing because if
you're symptomatic you want to get that
test to see if you have the corona virus
but moving forward this antibody test
which has been fast-tracked through the
FDA there are several of them available
this is a game-changer because we can
see who has had this virus who is now a
presumably immune going forward because
they've had it and they now have
antibodies to protect themselves they're
both very important they serve different
purposes and I'm glad you made that
distinction because it's important to
note but once you find out that you have
the antibody oh you're not the
administration is not looking for anyone
to engage in any kind of card-carrying
or something that says you know I have
antibodies I can go wherever I want I
mean we're not talking about this
tracing and tracking are we no I think
what you're hearing is contact tracing
so that's an important component
according to the experts if you are
identified as someone who has the corona
virus to know who you've been in contact
with so then we can find those contacts
and ensure that they
they can be traced so that's what the
contact tracing component of this is all
right Kaley mcenany thanks so much for
being here and congratulations happy
birthday